now there are reports of heavy fighting
between the Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces in Sudan the rsf
say they have downed a fighter jet over
ondemon sporadic gunfights and
airstrikes are taking place in the
capital of Khartoum well Heber Morgan
joins us now live from andamana near
khatu mahiba tell us more about what
seems to be going on
well the fighting
hours off Sunday morning around 5 a.m
local time which is around 3 A.M GMT in
the northern part of the city of
onderman the twin city of the capital
Khartoum now uh people in the area in
the northern part of andhurman say that
the rapid support forces tried to attack
the Sudanese armed position and this is
near an Army Air Base where the fight
suggests that have been targeting the
paramilitary rapid support forces have
been taking off from so the battles
continued with heavy airstrikes launched
by the Sudanese Army against the rapid
support forces fighters on the ground
there were also ground confrontations
and battles ongoing and it extended up
to the central part of the city of
umdurman but that's not the only place
where there's been fighting in the
Northern parts of the capital as well
there's been airstrikes launched there's
been artillery strikes in the eastern
part of the capital and the rapid
support forces said that it downed a
Sudanese Army fighter jet in the
northern part of the capital in the city
of Bahrain and now it's not clear what's
happened to the pilots who was flying
the fighter jet neither the Army nor the
rapid support forces gave an update
about his condition but people say that
they know that that those uh after the
ending of the ceasefire between the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Army on the first day of Eid on
Wednesday they knew that fighting would
intensify and now residents say that
they still remain trapped uh between the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Army as the fighting on the ground
continues with no political Solutions
inside
have been walking live for a sin on
demand thank you